finally Joe Biden went down to the
border and here he is just a little
short video and tell me if this is a guy
as you see him walking around does this
guy seem like he's in charge or knows
where he is
[Music]
they just throw him down there they
throw on The Aviator Shades they say Joe
just walk don't say anything just walk
okay so he got down there and what's
interesting is that you may remember a
couple weeks ago there was this video
going around of the El Paso Airport
where there were dozens if not hundreds
of illegal immigrants sleeping on the
floor and in the bathrooms and wandering
around outside and nobody really cared
about it AOC didn't tweet about it uh
now when you know 30 of them get to
Martha's Vineyard all hell breaks loose
okay fine but he was in El Paso uh Joe
Biden so what did they do before he got
there yeah they they cleaned it up
because you can't have the elderly man
pretending to be president seeing a
bunch of illegal aliens on the street I
mean that would that wouldn't be fair
of course this area it was had a lot of
police presence we've been reporting in
the past couple of weeks of police
coming here they've been arresting
people for maybe paraphernalia they had
access to to marijuana those types of
arrests we spoke to one woman we asked
her have people been cleaning this area
in preparation for President Biden's
visit one woman did tell us that yes the
city Chia seen City officials or city
employees out here cleaning the area in
preparation to President Biden's visit
I love that they're cleaning it up just
for Biden right because you wouldn't
want to Biden to see the the disaster
that reminded me did any of you guys go
to sleep away camp and you guys go to
sleep boy Camp yeah I remember in
Sleepaway Camp you know when I was there
when I was you know fifth grade sixth
grade whatever it was that right before
uh parents visiting day they would do
like two crazy days of cleaning like for
weeks before that you're living in filth
there's food everywhere and garbage and
whatever it's amazing like in sleep wake
up it's awesome but then right before
the parents get they clean it up the
parents come everyone's like oh this is
great it's all good the money money well
spent that's basically what they're
doing here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]